υπάρχουν τέτοίδος απιλές αλλά με σκοπό αυτό κάθε αυτό τα κέρδι σε χρηματικό ποσό μεχριστιμίς
όχι αυτό και πάλι είναι ένακαλό αλλά πάντοτε το αναμένουμε κάποια στιγμήεαι θα συμβεί γεντικά
όμως έχουμε πολύ καλήν αντα απόκρισυμπολύ καλή καλά αποτελέσματα προσπαθούμε να ελαεκτόοποιήσουμε τον κίνδυνο και
να ποκαταστήσουμε το το παιδί σε συνεργασία κι ε το σπίρι το παιδιούδιου που έχουμε
συνεργασία και με τις υπηρεσίες κοινωτοικής υεπιπαιρίας και με άλλος φορίς να κάνουμε το παιδί
να είναι σε επιό ασφαλή κατάσταση είναι τνα μην υπάρχει γι αυτός ο κίρδινος κλείνοντας
αιο μήνυμα στέλνεις στους γόνεις που ακούμε αυτή η συζήτηση που το παιδί ντος μπορεί
να είναι αρκετά το κινιτό στον υπολογιστεί κλεισμένο στο δωμάτιόν του τι πρέπει να κάνε
ένας γονέας για να αντιλιυθείι το παιδί του ισωςβιώνει κάτι το οποίο δεν περνα από
το μιάλόντο εγώ τους λέγω να μιλούν μέτα παιδο για τος να μιλομ με δια
ξέρεται γιατί γιατί έχουν περιπτώσεις που έχουν αναφερτήει τι αστυνομία παιδιά που τα θα διέξω
δεν έξεραν τη να κάν και ότα μίλησα στην αναστυνομία εν έχουν συχάσει σε ισαγωγικά
από τον κνδυνο αυτόν και έχουν ναθέσει γιατί γιατί το τέλος κατάφεραν και μίλησαν με
τους γωνίς τους και η γωνίς τους καλά εκανάν και θα στης πνομία άρα να
μιλούμε με τα παιδιά μας δηαδή αν βλέπον το παιδί μας ότι είναι απομονωμένο στο
δωμάτιο και είναι κάποιο δεν τροι δε συνάαυτρεφε δε βγαίνει έξω να πέξι να βγεί
έξω σε να πάει σε έναν κααφετέρειαν και λοιπάί υπάρχουν όρε σε αυτές οι αυτή
ισβητήσεις να μιλούμε τα παιδιά και εμείς είμαστε εκεί θα προσωπικώ είναι εκπαιδεμένων τους δει